créé le rassemblement a débuté il ya
environ une heure quel est l'état
d'esprit et sur la place louis lépine
vous voyez derrière moi ils sont environ
200 comme les 200 policiers qui se
trouvaient hier au niveau du bataclan
aujourd'hui c'est à l'appel de leurs
femmes que les manifestants se sont
rassemblés aujourd'hui l'association des
femmes de forces de l'ordre en colère et
présente aujourd'hui avec plus de ses
porte-paroles sort habitants qui a
appelé à ce rassemblement aujourd'hui
nous sommes juste en face qu'on la place
louis lépine juste en face du palais de
justice
au lieu donc hautement symbolique comme
le bataclan alors le mot d'ordre c'est
de défendre les forces de l'ordre contre
les accusations de violences policières
récurrentes et de racisme auquel on peut
assister depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois je vous propose d'écouter
certains témoignages que nous avons pu
recueillir sur place de la part des
personnes présentes ici c'était vraiment
un appel citoyen avec or habitants
et un soutien fort aux forces de l'ordre
par rapport à ces dernières semaines qui
ont été vraiment très très compliquée et
qui chaque jour des voleurs de puissants
plus semaine antique via notamment les
réseaux sociaux et les médias anglais
nous mais là aujourd'hui bas pour
manifester notre soutien à nos forces de
l'ordre à nos maris à nos femmes parce
qu'il ya aussi des marines et des
conjoints deux femmes policiers ou
gendarmes et c'est nécessaire d'être là
ses derniers bastions
c'est la dernière ligne et si c'est le
ciel bête je sais pas ce qu'on va
devenir
alors ma présence ici est avant tout
pour soutenir nos forces de l'ordre sur
ce que je fais depuis des années parce
que je trouve ça inacceptable la façon
dont ils sont traités
je trouve ça très important que les
citoyens montrent leur soutien aux
forces de l'ordre à tous nos uniformes
alors il ya quelques minutes on a pu
entendre une marseillaise que les
manifestants sur place ont chanté avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé plus
généralement ici tout se passe dans le
plus grand des calmes et là le
rassemblement devrait prendre fin d'ici
d'ici deux heures on vous tiendra bien
évidemment au courant de ce qui se passe
ici sur place
merci kirill kotick offre directeur de
la place louis lépine à paris